so we've made kong bigger it's a fair
fight now right
well godzilla's got armor plating and
the atomic breath
and the tail so he's basically got an
extra fighting appendage
so what if we gave kong an axe
[Music]
so my apologies to anybody who looks
forward to my more
uh fabulous looks but honestly it's not
worth getting done up for this movie
godzilla vs kong there will be spoilers
later down the line i will give you a
heads up before we
get there but let's start broad strokes
this is probably the monster verse movie
i like the least if i were going to rank
the whole thing
up to this point kong skull i and none
of these are without reservation
to be clear kong skull island would be
at the top godzilla king of the monsters
godzilla 2014
and this at the bottom the
issue honestly is the clash of
tones because this does
legitimately try to be a sequel to
both godzilla king of the monsters and
kong skull island
if i were to say which one it was more
strictly in terms of how much
run time is dedicated to it i would say
it's slightly more a sequel to
kong skull island than it is godzilla
and certainly kong gets a heck of a lot
more
um characterization and humanizing than
godzilla ever does
though i'm not sure humanizing godzilla
would have been a good idea anyway but
my point is
this feels like it is trying to marry
two franchises that actually
as they've been built don't blend
that great so here's the thing
the reason i like kong skull island the
most is because it was the one most
willing to be
at least a little bit silly and seem to
be aware that it was
a little bit silly now it still treated
things with a fair amount of seriousness
especially when it came to the violence
and the death of characters and all of
that
godzilla both 2014 and king of the
monsters
by contrast has treated things with a
much more
dooming gloom this is all very serious
sort of tone which while not
my preference is a valid way to
depict these events and these kinds of
films it's
again not what i prefer i like at least
a dose of silly
because the concepts are inherently
silly but
they opted not to do that with the
godzilla movies and that's fine the
problem is
here we now have a clashing of tones
because
the overall tone of the thing is
godzilla's dower doom and gloom like
things are
screwed the human race is not gonna make
it kind of tone
clashing with frankly
stuff that it's too silly for
because a lot of the plot feels much
more at home with khan which makes sense
because he takes up more time so like
it's picking up
on things like the hollow earth theory
and a lot of the stuff that goes on
on that end of things i won't get into
specific silly hit spoilers
a lot of that stuff fits pretty decently
with kong skull island i mean it's a
little sillier it's scaled up
silly but that doesn't really fit at all
with godzilla and the
the level of ridiculousness combined
with how po-faced the whole thing is
it just didn't blend for me and
the uh the cast of characters the human
casted characters doesn't do
a lot to help there's a very odd mixing
and matching in terms of
who gets brought back and more in
at least from my estimation more
glaringly who doesn't
so they bring back millie bobby brown
and also the guy who plays her dad but
he honestly is a glorified extra in this
so they bring her back but her
involvement in the plot honestly
it's incredibly coincidental because she
just
happens to already be located in the one
place where she could be to find the one
person that would actually get her
roped into things so that she would
physically get involved
and be in the right place for stuff to
happen it all kicks off on a
massive coincidence which can be fairly
standard but generally i find it's
easier to get away with these massive
coincidences
in a sillier film than a more serious
one and because the overall tone of this
again is a little bit more in line with
godzilla
than with king kong despite the fact
that plot-wise it's more kong
then you know that massive coincidence
that gets her involved i'm
and i mean another thing is was it worth
it
is it worth putting up with the massive
coincidence that gets her involved in
order to have her involved and
not really she's not a detriment but her
presence doesn't add anything except a
little bit of continuity and a couple of
people pointing out that she was
involved with previous
previous films but the fact that she was
involved in previous films actually
brings
nothing particular to the table but i
said more glaringly there's who they
didn't bring back and that for me
really stuck out because as i said they
reintroduced this hollow earth concept
which came up in kong skull island
now in kong skull island they had a
character who was an academic who'd been
laughed at for that theory
who got a lot of confirmation from me on
skull island and
who was brought back as an older actor
joe morton in the
in this case and godzilla king of the
monsters reiterating
he is still around and this story
does have a use and a requirement for an
academic
with an interest in hollow earth did
they bring him back
no no they introduced a brand new
blandly attractive
white guy why why not just bring
back joe morton and have him play that
same character
i cannot think of any reason other than
just we can't have an
older black guy be the lead we just
can't
we'll screw you yeah you could there's
like all due respect alexander skarsgard
he
brings nothing and the presence of his
character when there was an existing
character who perfectly fit the mold of
what he actually has to do
yeah no i actually kind of took offense
at that and
i am gonna start getting into more
specifics but before i do let me say
i'm not gonna say there's no fun to be
had some of the
uh spectacle of it is in fact kind of
spectacular
i don't feel like adam wingard i think
i'm pronouncing that right
handles the sense of scale as well as
the previous directors in this franchise
have
the the monsters don't feel as big and
he's also very
fond of the swishy swishy camera kind of
you know fancy shots where the camera i
care
uh a monster falls in the camera goes
with the monster
and like loops back around it's it's too
much
it's not necessary it doesn't really add
all that much but
you know there's fun to be had in
elements of the raw
experience but it's got it's got a
script
written for a silly movie but it's
taking itself as seriously as the two
previous godzilla movies did
it's a clash of tone the characters
aren't all that interesting
and i just i didn't have as much fun
there's some fun but i didn't have that
much i am going to start getting into
spoilers now so i can [ __ ] about more
specific things
so that's your spoiler warning so right
off the bat
when we introduce kong who is looking a
little bit older which yeah
as a from a visual standpoint i kind of
appreciate that he looks a little older
looks a little weathered you know he's
on his island and it opens with this
actually very strange and again kind of
silly but
when we stay with kong the silly works a
bit better
thing where it's like we're watching his
morning routine and there's a song
playing and then we find out the song is
actually playing and it's like maybe
supposed to soothe him and there's this
girl
there with like a kong doll and he's
like they have a connection
somehow ah now initially i got a little
bit excited because i'm like ooh
are we going to reestablish the natives
on this island and like
give them some agency and a little bit
of justice and characterize them
and then immediately finding out like oh
she seems to be the daughter of this
other woman i'm like oh no we're
definitely not doing that now
but then to find out later no she
actually is from the tribe
but she's the last survivor and
basically bears
no hallmarks other than like a thing on
her head and a necklace
to indicate that she was ever part of
this and she was ever
a native to this island all the markers
that would indicate
and give weight to this civilization
that was there
that really didn't bring much and was a
little bit
in kong skull island i talked about that
in my review
but you know i thought maybe this was a
chance to make amends and like really
give her agency but the fact that she is
a native of that island has
basically zero to do with anything
because they claim
it's like kong bonds with her because
like he's a protector of the people who
were on the island except that honestly
they could have just had
any child and like i said bears none of
the markers she's using american sign
language for crying out loud so
for all intents and purposes she could
have just been the biological daughter
of the woman who has basically adopted
her
as far as the plot goes so that was
annoying
part of my frustration is they had a lot
of pieces to work with that they just
don't and then the things they choose to
work with are
i'm not sure they were worth reusing
so we get a follow-up on the post-credit
scene from
godzilla king of the monsters which was
the head of godor falling into the hands
of charles dance sadly charles dance
does not come back but apparently he
sold it to the obviously
evil mega corporation which again still
brings up the problem that i had with
that post credit scene there's my review
for godzilla king of the monsters where
i got into that but
long story short the fact that he
collected that thing didn't fit with the
motivations he was given in that film
and now i guess we're supposed to just
assume he sold it for money
but he was part of a plan in that movie
to
basically wipe out a huge chunk of
humanity which would have disrupted
society
and economies like why why would someone
who had that
as their stated and actions indicated it
in fact was their goal
why would they want money
what i mean that's
that's my hang up because it actually
doesn't come into play all that matters
is it's now in the hands of
apex apex cybernetics the totally
kosher sound like that's another thing
that i mean
it is so stupefyingly
obvious that apex are going to be the
villains
and the movie seems to know that it
doesn't try and hide it it doesn't try
to play it as a twist
even though in universe in story some
characters get surprised by this like
oh look at that we went on this
expedition funded by apex and the person
in
associated with apex who has been
grouchy and confrontational the whole
time betrayed us for the resources who
could have foreseen this coming
apparently not the characters
the movie does seem to assume that the
audience knows so it's not insulting but
again it speaks to that clash of tone
because this is a cartoonishly
evil corporation in terms of
what they're doing the means they're
using to do it the lengths they're
prepared to go to
it it is umbrella corporations level
of what the hell and honestly i think
the only time any film has ever gotten
away with that was really the original
alien but it was because the idea of a
corporation as cold-hearted as wailing
yutani wasn't a ubiquitous
cultural staple yet it was a newer idea
in 1979
it's not now but it's a silly idea and
it can work in a sillier movie but again
the overall tone of this thing is too
serious for me to take it seriously
because you're doing
cartoonish villainy and like
i'm not even gonna cite specific
examples but can i just the dialogue
sucks dialogue blows in this thing
and i'm not sure the dialogue had been
that good in the previous movies
but they found some actors here and
there who could make
it feel more lively honestly um
in conscious island they had a lot of
them samuel jackson john goodman brie
larson uh
john c reilly especially tom hiddleston
they were able to bring some life to
what otherwise might have been some kind
of dumb dialogue
and even in godzilla king of the
monsters you have people like bradley
whitford
really livening things up and doing
banter so rapid fire that like
it feels fun even though the information
being conveyed is
you know it's exposition 90 of the time
here all these actors honestly
they're too bland they're too bland and
or they're p
they're playing such arch characters
that like there's no
there's no nuance there's no bounce and
every time characters start talking
i'm just kind of like
[Music]
um oh there was one i'm just rambling at
this point
there was one kind of nifty little
subversion that i did like
until they got to the point of how they
resolved it and then i was like oh for
god's sake
so they have this thing so i told you
they were going to be spoilers
mechagodzilla is in the finale which i
half called i didn't call mechagodzilla
specifically
but i did call him my godzilla king of
the monsters review that
ultimately kong and godzilla were going
to team up against the third threat and
i also said it would be the lazy option
and look
haha they did it so um mechagodzilla
shows up and
is being the the the little trio
of millie bobby brown and this paranoid
podcaster
and her and uh millie bobby brown's
friend
um he was actually good he made some of
the dialogue work
so i'll put his name down here because i
can't remember it off the top of my head
i i like him he's a good presence but
like
he's he's trying to hack the system
but what's fun there is you expect oh he
just
needs a little time and he'll get in but
he just like he just gets stonewalled
every step of the way
and he admits like i don't all i know
how to do is like pirate stuff and i
know a little html i thought i could do
this and i clearly can't
and i love that that the person set up
to like be the hacker just
isn't actually very good at it and
overestimated their own abilities
but then uh the way they actually end up
resolving this
is to dump it ends up being whiskey but
just liquid
on the control panel it shorts things
out and kind of stalls mechagodzilla now
the thing is
mechagodzilla at that point is
self-powered self-sustaining
self-sufficient
then thinking for itself
so you built a machine that was capable
of growing almost totally autonomous
and yet was capable of being glitched
out
if at a facility some distance away
somebody accidentally spilled the coffee
really and again that's the that's the
silly clashing with the tone if the tone
of the thing overall
had been a little sillier a little
less dour then honestly i probably could
have rolled with that but it's that
clash
again oh and another thing if you want
me
and maybe this is me maybe other people
don't have this hang up
but if you want me to have fun
with giant monsters slamming each other
around the city
it would really help if you didn't keep
cutting to shots that reestablishes how
many innocent civilians there are in the
area
like look there's plenty of films out
there that disregard the civilian
casualties especially if it's trying to
be fun they tend to minimize that or
throw some hasty line about
oh city's already evacuated it was fine
yeah right it was
but regardless that at least is an
acknowledgment that
if you're here for the monster fight you
don't want to be reminded that hey
people are probably getting stomped
underneath but this film
kept cutting to these ground level
things where we see people running and
screaming
in the middle of the fight so like i
keep getting taken out of the fight
because you're reminding me of how many
innocent people are dying which isn't
fun that fits the tone of say the 2014
godzilla where he was more of a threat
and treated like a force of nature kind
of thing yes in that case
it would make sense to remind me of the
civilian casualties because
he's a walking disaster here it's
supposed to be a fun monster fight why
are you reminding me how many innocent
people are dying because you know what
that's not fun and it's that back and
forth it's that juxtaposition it's that
clash of the two tones of the film
it is trying to be fun but is doing too
many things that would only work if the
entire thing was more serious
but too much of what's going on is too
ridiculous for it to work
if the whole thing is going to be
treated seriously it just
kind of bottoms out
and by the end i was just kind of
okay so that was a thing that's kind of
it
interestingly this does nothing to set
up a further sequel
no post credits no nothing and given
that
it seemed like as soon as the as
legendary was doing
both godzilla and kong the assumption
well not the assumption
pretty much immediately as soon as they
started handling both properties it was
built up these two are going to fight
i find it interesting that they're not
directly setting up anything to follow
on from this
it's like they have no plan
and if this is meant to be the end game
it kind of ends the whole thing on a bit
of a damp squib
godzilla versus kong did you see it
what'd you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it i've got a patreon there
might be a link up there or youtube
might still be broken and you might have
to go down to this
description for it that is how i pay my
bills
it is what enables this entire operation
to keep going
and even if you're not able to do that
youtube memberships are an option now
there are perks in both cases
but you also don't have to the usual
stuff like share subscribe it all helps
me out
and that would be greatly appreciated
but you don't have to do that either
because at the end of the day
you're the council i'm just running the
meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned happy trans
day of visibility
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye